[موسيقى]
كبرت ، كان الأمر صعبًا لكنك تعلم أنه
يجب عليك الاستفادة من
الطريقة التي تظهر بها في الحياة ، لذلك
أعني أنني لم أتخرج ويجب أن أحصل على
[موسيقى]
كانت والدتي ذات رأس طائر كانت تستخدمه
لأتصرف عندما كنت طفلاً صغيراً
أو عندما أنجبتني أو أياً كان ما هي ،
لم تفعل ذلك أكثر من
والدي ، لقد كان مثل اللص ،
لذا فأنت تعلم أنني حصلت على ما أحتاجه
عندما كنت طفلاً ولكن
كان لدي  طفولة سيئة من الصف الأول ،
كنت طفلاً رائعًا ، أعني أنني لم أكن حقًا في
الصف الأول حتى
الصف المتوسط أو الثالث ، عندما تركت طف
لتي التي كانت سيئة وع
ت مع شخص آخر كنت في ال
ائلة ، كنت صديقًا لأمي وم
مثل الصف الثالث  منذ أن
غادرت المنزل الذي لم
يعجبني وذهبت إلى شخص آخر
عندما بدأت في القيام بأشياء سيئة ، فأنت تعلم فقط
أنني كنت متسترًا وأنني تركت الدراسة كما لو أنني لا
أتذكر على الأرجح مثل الصف العاشر لذا
أمي  قلت إنك لست مضطرًا للذهاب إلى
المدرسة إذا كنت لا تريد ذلك
فقلت إنني أموت لن أعود إليها أبدًا
المدرسة ولا
أريد العودة إلى المدرسة أبدًا ، أعتقد أن ذلك يسري
في دمي ،
لذا أعني أنني كنت دائمًا
لا أعرف أنني كنت ذلك الطفل السيئ
، لذلك أردت دائمًا أن أكون
أفضل ، ولهذا السبب أعني أن ذهني قد
صنع  أريد أن أفعل هذا
لبقية حياتي ، لذا
فأنت تعلم أنني أعني أن هذا
ما أفعله  لذلك
يجب أن
أساعدهم في الاستحمام والملابس والتغذية
وأشياء من هذا
القبيل والكثير من الأشخاص الذين لم أقابلهم من
قبل ،
لذا فإن الذهاب إلى
منازل جديدة وأشياء من هذا القبيل أمر مخيف ، لكني
أعتقد أنك تعتاد نوعًا ما  بعد
فترة منالوقت ،
خرجت من هذا المجال لفترة من الوقت
وكنت مثل اسمحوا لي أن أحاول البيع بالتجزئة لمعرفة كيف
يحدث
ذلك ، ثم مع البيع بالتجزئة شعرت
وكأنني موظف آخر كما لو أنني لم أحدث
فرقًا في حياة أي شخص.
عندما
قررت الحصول على درجة التمريض ،
كنت أفعل ذلك منذ أربع سنوات حتى
الآن  حاصل على شهادة تمريض جيدة ،
يمكنني العمل في دور رعاية المسنين ومنازل الناس ،
أحب مساعدة الناس مثل هذا
الشيء الأكبر الذي
لا أعرفه أثناء نشأتي ، لقد اتصلت دائمًا
بأشخاص لمساعدتي كثيرًا لذلك
أنا  مثل لماذا لا تستسلم
كأنني شخص مهتم
[موسيقى]
ميسي لي ، حسنًا ، كيف كان يومك
كان جيدًا ، نعم لم تراني يوم
الجمعة كان كل شيء على ما يرام ،
أراك لا ، لم أكن هنا من أجلك  يوم
الجمعة
اتصلوا وقالوا لي ألا
أحضر ،
أنت لست حارًا جدًا ، نعم ، حسنًا
، هل أنت جائع ، نعم ، حسنًا ، هل
تريد ساندويتش جيلي زبدة الفول السوداني ،
حسنًا ، سأضع هذا عليك إذا
حصلت أيضًا  حار ، يمكنك سحبها مرة أخرى ،
حسنًا ،
حسنًا ، سأعود بعد قليل ،
سأحضر لك شيئًا لتأكله
بمساعدة الناس لي يعني أنه
مع أي شيء
يحتاجون إليه فقط إذا كان مجرد شراء البقالة أو
تذكيرهم بذلك
خذ دوائهم أو قل مهلا
هل أكلت اليوم ،
دعني أصلح لك شيئًا لتأكله فقط
أي شيء  ver يحتاجون مني أنا
على استعداد للمساعدة
لأنني عانيت دائمًا في الحياة
وأردت دائمًا أن يساعدني شخص ما
بهذا
الشكل ولم يكن لدي ذلك دائمًا حتى
أتمكن من رد الجميل للناس  هذا
ما يحدث لي فرقًا
يجعلني أشعر بالدفء من الداخل ،
دعني أرى لي ، ها هو طفلك ،
هل يمكنك الجلوس بما يكفي لتناول الطعام ،
حسنًا ، دعني أنتظر
إنها شطيرة زبدة الفول السوداني ،
تتذكرني أخبرك أنني سأجعلك
نعم ، حسنًا ، انظر إلى الماء الخاص بك هنا
إذا
كنت بحاجة إليه وسأراك بعد قليل على ما
يرام ، لقد
تركت الدراسة على الأرجح مثل الصف العاشر ،
لذا
فأنا بالكاد أريد الحصول على وظيفة ولكنك تعلم
أنني حصلت على طفل و
كل ما تعرفه أحاول أن أفعل
ما يجب أن أفعله لرعاية طفلي
والقيام بكل ما يجب علي فعله
للاعتناء بنفسي ،
هذا هو رقم واحد ، لذا فأنت تعلم أنني أعني
أنه من الصعب هنا معرفة ماذا  أعني أن
الناس يموتون كل يوم
الناس الذين نشأت معهم إما
ماتوا أو في السجن
يستخدمه شخص ما  عندما أكون معه أطلق
النار على شرطي أطلق النار على شرطي وحصل على 30 إلى 60 عامًا ،
لذا أعني أن هذا ما يحدث على الرغم
من أنك يجب أن تكون ذكيًا
عندما تكبر
حتى لا تكون في السجن إلى الأبد  أو
تحدث وأقتل شخصًا ما
لمدة ست سنوات سيرًا على الأقدام ، يمكنني أن أفعل ذلك يمكنني
الحفاظ عليه لأنني لن
أطلب المال من الناس ، سأذهب
لأحصل على أموالي ، أنت تعرف ما أعنيه ، لذا
فأنا أجتهد وكل شيء لكني أفعل  في
الغالب بالنسبة
لك ، تعرف ما أعنيه أن
أعتني بأي شيء يمكنني التفكير فيه
خاصة مع طفلي الذي يكبر ليكون
أيًا كان ، لكني
أعتقد أنه من الأفضل
لك أن تعرف أنني أعني أن أكون ذكيًا هنا عندما
يكون لديك طفل ، فأنت تعرف ماذا  أعني
لكني أحمي ابنتي ،
أنت تعرف ما أعنيه أنها
أذكى ، إنها مثلي تمامًا
[
موسيقى] يجب على مالكولم البقاء في المنزل لأنه
مريض لذا سيبقى مع
جون
وكريستينا ، وعادة ما تصل الحافلة إلى هنا في مثل 7
-أحيانًا تتأخر على الرغم من أنك
يجب أن تذهب إلى الحضانة اليوم
رغم أنك بخير وأمي  سأصطحبك
من هناك لأنني يجب أن أعمل
[موسيقى]
أوه
ابدأ من أجلي مرة أخرى ، هيا
[موسيقى
] دائمًا ما كانت هناك أمهات عازبات في
المجتمعات الأمريكية الأفريقية منذ
العبودية
منذ أن أخذوا الرجال  من
العائلات لإنشاء
ما يحدث الآن ، هذا مجرد
استمرار لما
بدأ عندما أتوا بنا إلى هنا لأول مرة
وازدهرت العائلات التي كانت تقودها
نساء من أصل أفريقي ،
وأعتقد أن الأمر يتعلق بمسألة هؤلاء
المراهقين الذين لديهم أطفال
ولا يمكنك  توقع أن يبلغ من العمر 14 أو 15 عامًا ،
أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، لم يبلغ من العمر ما
يكفي ليكون أباً وهو طفل
لا يتحدث عنه أحد أنهم يتخطون
كل الطريق حتى
يتحدثوا إلى الطفل بعد أن
يفعلوا شيئًا و  يلقون باللوم على عدم
وجود أب
جيد ، كان والدك طفلاً ولم يكن رجلاً
ولا يمكنك الانتقال إلى المنزل
مع والدتك التي كانت في نفس
العمر 15 16. أعني أنهم لا يستطيعون
القيادة حتى الآن  الذهاب إلى نادٍ
لكنهم يريدونهم أن
يكونوا آباءً  ake sense
[موسيقى
] الكثير من الشابات يقمن
ببرامج تعليمية مدتها 18 شهرًا ستجد الكثير من
الممرضات
في مجال التمريض سواء كانوا
مساعدين للممرضات حتى
الممرضات ولكنهم
يجعلون النساء يتجهن مباشرة  وضع البقاء على قيد الحياة
لأنه إذا كنت تعرف أنك إذا كنت تبلغ من العمر 14 أو 15 عامًا
وكان لديك طفل ،
فهناك شيء في أسرتك دفعك
حتى إلى الرغبة في طفل
يقول الكثير منهم
أنني أريد شخصًا ما يحبني
[موسيقى]
كيف قابلت  والدتي الصغيرة ، حسناً
عندما كان عمري حوالي 17 عامًا كنت
على الإنترنت ،
قابلت فتاة بدأت أتحدث على
الإنترنت أو أيا كان
، وحصلت مع هذه الفتاة ، من المفترض
أن تكون هذه الفتاة اللطيفة ذات البشرة الفاتحة
ولكن بحلول الوقت  لقد وصلت إلى هناك ، لم
تكن الفتاة التي كنت أتوقعها ،
كان لدي الشخص الخطأ في ذهني ، لذلك
كان شخصًا
ما لن أنجب طفلًا مع طفلي البالغ من العمر
خمسة الآن ، لذا
فأنت تعرف ما أعنيه أنني أحب
الطفل ولكن الأم الصغيرة أنا  لا تهتم حقًا
ولكنك تعلم أنه عليك أن تفعل ما
عليك فعله أحيانًا  أعرف ما أعنيه
أنها ستكبر لتكون أيًا كانت ولكني
أفرط في حمايتها ، سأكون
قريبًا منها في جميع الأوقات ،
سأكون دائمًا هنا ،
أنت تعرف ما أعنيه لذلك أنا دائمًا
أنا أعلم عن قرب أين هي ، لذلك
أنا أعتني بطفلي ، نعم أفعل
بطريقة أشعر
أنه ليس لديها ما يدعو للقلق كما لو
أنني الوحيد الذي يمكنها الوثوق
به لأنني والدنا إذا فعلت ذلك
تحتاج إلى شيء
يمكنها دائمًا الاعتماد عليّ مع مرور الوقت ،
تعرف ما أعنيه
أنني أشعر أنني قوي بما يكفي لأكون مثل
ما تحتاج إليه
الآن كما يمكنني أن أقول أنه الآن
[موسيقى]
سأفعل  اشطف هذا من أجلك
، ثم سأعيده إليك ،
لكني أريد فقط التأكد من أنه نظيف
بهذه الطريقة ليس لديك أي طبول
حوله ،
حسنًا ، إنه آمن دائمًا من آسف ،
لقد استعدت يومي بسبب
أنا حامل ، ليس لدي
الكثير من الرفع وأشياء من هذا القبيل ، لكن إذا
لم أكن حاملاً ، فسيتعين علي
القيام بالكثير من الرفع
والتنظيف والأشياء  من هذا القبيل ،
سأراك غدًا ، حسنًا ، حسنًا ، حسنًا ،
ضع هذا من أجلك هنا اختر
شطيرة
حتى أتمكن من أخذها مرة أخرى في غرفة المعيشة ،
وسأراك لاحقًا ، حسنًا ، حسنًا ،
أحبك
]
إذا كان هذا صبيًا ،
فسيكون اسمه
جيرميا وإذا كانت فتاة
فستكون تشياري
[موسيقى] ،
فأنا أتمنى أن يكون هناك صبي على الرغم من أنني
لا أستطيع التعامل مع موقف فتاة أخرى ،
فإن الدولة تساعدني في ذلك
التأمين الصحي أحصل على تأمين صحي من الولاية ،
أحصل على قسائم طعام من الولاية
، والآن أحصل على
رعاية نهارية منهم أيضًا كما يساعدون في
تمهيد كل ما يأتون به من
مساعدة كبيرة بطريقة ما
ولكن بمجرد أن أبدأ في صنع  مبلغًا معينًا
من المال أفقد كل ذلك ، لذا فهو
نوع من الوضع الذي يخسر فيه الربح ،
فهم يساعدونك حتى يشعروا
بأنك تكسب ما يكفي من المال لدفع ثمن ذلك
ثم يتوقفون عن مساعدتك
ولكنهم الآن يساعدونني
جميعًا  حسنًا ، أنت جاهز ، حسنًا ،
دعنا نذهب حبيبي ضع غطاء الرأس على لقد حصلت على
شيء  من أجلك ،
ما الذي تراه ، انظر ،
أوه ، نعم ، لم تكن تبحث عنك
حتى لم
تدخله ووضعت حزام الأمان على
ما حصلت عليه ، أليس مهرتي الصغيرة ،
هل أنت جائع ،
نعم ،
هذا ما أريده  لأفعل ذلك ، أريد بيع
المخدرات
لأنك تعلم أن هذا أفضل بالنسبة
لكيفية نشأتي في الحياة ، فأنت تعلم ما أعنيه
أنني سأكون هنا في الخارج 100
لا أحد يستطيع أن يمنعني ، أنظر إلى نفسي
لأنني مثل الرئيس و  ثقل موازن
لأنني أستطيع الحصول عليك ، يمكنني الحصول على أي شيء
يخبرك بالمخدرات وهذا ما اعتدت القيام
به كما تعلمون ، أعني أنني سأموت من أجل
هذا ،
سأذهب إلى السجن كثيرًا لقد كنت في السجن
مثل 10 مرات  حتى تعرف ما أعنيه
بيع المخدرات التي يتم القبض عليها
جيدًا ، قلت دائمًا إنني أريد المال أو
أي شيء آخر وأنت تعلم أنه كان
صراعًا في
محاولة الحصول على المال
ومحاولة الحفاظ على نفسي
والتأكد من أنني حصلت على ما يكفي من المال للحصول على
إنه في جيبي كل يوم ،
لذا فأنا أعبث مع الأشخاص الشرعيين
لأكون كما أحب أن أكون في
مأزقي.
للعبث مع الرؤساء الشرعيين
لكي تعرف ما أعنيه أن يفهمني الناس
لأنك تعلم أنني أعني أنني لن أقصر على اختصارك ،
فأنا لست كذلك ولكني
أحاول تحسين مثل
مقدار  يمكن أن أكون
في الرابع عشر من يوليو / تموز ، قُتل ابني في
الشارع
منذ ذلك الحين ، ولديه
ابن يدعى مركز التسوق جايد حاملًا لمدة أربعة أشهر
في الوقت الذي
قُتل فيه ، لذلك كان لديه ابن الآن
يبلغ من العمر 13
عامًا لم أفكر أبدًا في ذلك.
حدث معه ،
كان لدينا الكثير من أفراد الأسرة الذين
ماتوا بسبب القتل ،
ابني ، ابن أخي وابن عمي ،
أطلق أحدهم النار على
كل واحد منهم في الحرارة ،
أصيب ابني برصاصة في رأسه ،
أصيب ثلاثة من أبناء إخوتي بالرصاص في رأسي.
لقد أصيب ابن عمه برصاصة في صدره ،
لذا نعم ، لكن كل ذلك حدث في
شوارع مدينة بالتيمور ،
لذا بشكل عام كان هناك ستة أفراد من العائلة
قتلوا
ولم يتم حل أي من القضايا حتى
الآن عندما توقف عائلتنا عن
إيذاء
تسعة أطفال كان  تركت وراءها
ليس الأطفال بدون  بالنسبة لأبي ، أنا
أفكك أسر العائلات
تتألم بسبب عدم معرفة ما
يجب القيام به وقد سئمنا ذلك ،
أود أن أقول إن 60 جريمة قتل لم يتم حلها ،
ربما تم إطلاق النار على شخص ما ، وهذه فكرة سيئة
هناك
[موسيقى] أجنبية
كلنا  اعلم أن الشخص الذي جاء
من أعلى الشارع ونزل إلى هنا
وقال إنه تم إطلاق النار عليهم ،
هذا كل ما تعرفه مع الضحية ، فقد
تم فصله الآن
[موسيقى]
لأننا نشعر أنه يتعين علينا
حل القضية وهذا ليس صحيحًا
[موسيقى  ]
كانت طفولتي صعبة للغاية ، كانت أمي
هي الوحيدة في حياتي
التي عملت بها طوال الوقت ، لذا لم
أتمكن من رؤيتها حقًا ، لذا كنت إما
أقفز من
منزل العائلة أو منزل صديق
وأشياء من هذا
القبيل احتفظت بها  سقف فوقنا ، لكنني
لم أقضي الوقت معها أبدًا
، كانت تعمل دائمًا تعمل
معي وزوجي ، نحن نمر
بفصل الآن ،
وسأقول فقط إنه اتخذ بعض
الخيارات السيئة في الحياة عندما يتعلق الأمر
لقد كذب علي بشأن البعض  أشياء لذا فإن الكثير
من النساء لديهن مشاكل ثقة
وأنا أعلم أنني أثق في القضايا الكبيرة
بالنسبة لي
من الصعب الانفتاح عليها والثقة
بها
ولكن الكثير من النساء اللواتي يشعرن وكأنهن
معي أشعر وكأن الرجل من المفترض أن يفعل ذلك
دعم المنزل الذي من المفترض أن
يدفعوا جميع الفواتير ، تأكد من أننا جيدون ،
لذا إذا أردنا أن نكون أمًا في المنزل ،
فيمكن أن
يكون الكثير من الرجال هنا ليسوا هكذا
بعد الآن كما ألوم على ذلك  أمهاتهم
لم يربوا كما لو
أنهم لم يربوا ليكونوا رجالًا صالحين ، لذا
[موسيقى
] الكثير من الإناث يكرهون فقط أن يقولوا إن
لديهم أطفالًا مع أي شخص ،
فهذا لا يحدث بشكل صحيح وينتهي بهم الأمر
بأن يكونوا عازبين
الآباء الكثير من الرجال الذين أعرف أنهم
واجهوا مشاكل في سن مبكرة وهذا نوع من
متابعتهم مع تقدمهم في السن حتى
ينظر إليهم الناس ويصبحون كما لو أنه
مثير للمشاكل أو صانع الجريمة
أو يبيع المخدرات وهم لا يفعلون ذلك.  لا أريد
منحهم العدد الطبيعي من التاسعة إلى الخامسة ، لذا
يتعين عليهم اللجوء إلى القيام
بأشياء أخرى ، وفي بعض الأحيان يتعين
عليك صنع  يلتقي الأشخاص بغض النظر عن كيفية
قيامك بذلك حتى لو كان مجرد صخب أو
أيًا كان ما عليك القيام به ،
فالناس يكسبون نفقاتهم ويقابلون أطفالي في الواقع
لديهم نفس الأب ، اسمه مالكولم
والواحد الذي أنا حامل به هو والدهم أيضًا
أم مالكولم أيضًا على الرغم من
أنني حامل بهذا الطفل ، فمن دواعي
سروري أن أعتبرها نعمة
لأنني أعرف بغض النظر عن ما
لن يضعه الله علي أكثر مما يمكنني
تحمله ، لذا فأنا أعرف
لا  بغض النظر عما أعانيه من سوء حظي ،
سأخرج في القمة
في النهاية
لأنني مصمم على أن أكون قويًا
بغض النظر عن ما
لدي طفلان بالفعل يبحثان
عني وأريد  ليعرفوا أنه
بغض النظر عن مدى صعوبة الحياة ،
ستجعلها دائمًا في المقدمة إذا حاولت
لا يمكنك الاستسلام لأنك إذا استسلمت
فسوف يتخلى الناس عنك
[موسيقى
] لم أترعرع عند ولادتي  والداي
لكنني نشأت على يد أجدادي
وكانوا أجدادًا حقيقيين
لم يكونوا في
الثلاثين من العمر عندما ولدت كما لو
كانت الدورة تبلغ من العمر 15 عامًا  إذا أنجبت طفلًا
ثم أنجبت طفلًا في سن 15
أو 16 عامًا
، فهذه هي الدورة إذا كان عمرك 14 أو 15 عامًا
وأنت الآن في حالة رفاهية لأنك الآن
في
دورة وتعتقد أن الناس مدينون لك بشيء
ما  تعرف لأنك نشأت في
منزل لم يذهب إليه أحد للعمل ولكنهم حصلوا
على شيك كل أسبوعين ، أنت تعلم أن
هذه المشكلة
لا توجد مساءلة
ولا يعتقد الناس أن هناك أي خطأ في
ذلك
في المجتمعات التي لا يزال
يعتبر من المحرمات.  هذا يحدث ،
أعتقد أن التحديات الرئيسية التي تواجه النساء اللاتي
لا يملكن الموارد لتخطي
الظروف الصعبة منذ بداية
طفولتهن تحاول شاباتنا أن يكبرن نساءً
قبل 20 عامًا من
وقتهن ونضجهن فقط لن
يعملن
أو اجتماعيًا أو  اقتصاديًا لأن
الأطفال الذين يبلغون من العمر 14 عامًا لا يستطيعون الحصول
على راتب من شخص بالغ ،
أعتقد أن
عنصريتنا التي تواجهها النساء الأمريكيات من أصل أفريقي هي أكثر
منهجية ، وقد أجرؤ على القول إننا
نعاني من التمييز الجنسي أكثر من العنصرية
أكثر من  ذكور من أصل أفريقي ،
نعم ، ستخرج ،
ستخرج ، لن نتركها ، هيا ،
دعنا نذهب إلى السيارة التي فقدنا
مكاننا بالفعل في أكتوبر ،
وانتهت سيارتي بالتعطل
ولم أتمكن من العمل عليها  الوقت حتى
سمحوا لي بالذهاب
، وهكذا انتهى بنا المطاف في الملجأ
لأنه مرة أخرى إذا لم تتمكن من الوصول إلى العمل
ودفع فواتيرك ،
فلن يكون لديك منزل لذلك
من المفترض أن  أبقى في
المأوى لمدة ثلاثة أشهر ،
أنا في فترة الثلاثة أشهر الخاصة بي مع
راتبي الذي أحضره إلى المنزل ،
لدي ما يكفي من المال لسداد تأمين سيارتي
ووضع الغاز في سيارتي ، ولن أكذب حتى
لهذا السبب هو صعب للغاية  بالنسبة لي
للخروج من المأوى
لأنني بالكاد حصلت على المال لدفع مدفوعات سيارتي ،
كيف سأدفع الإيجار
ولكني لا أعرف وهذا نوع من
الوضع الذي أنا فيه الآن كما فقدت
كل شيء  أنا نوع من إعادة البناء
الحمد لله أن لدينا ضريبة دخل
وكان ذلك قادرًا على مساعدتي
في استعادة القليل من أشيائي ولكن
ذلك د  لا تدوم إلى الأبد ،
لذا آمل ألا أفقد وظيفتي ،
حلمي الرئيسي
هو الحصول على مكان خاص بي مثل امتلاك منزل ،
وهذا حلمي الرئيسي هو امتلاك
منزل وليس علي العودة في العرض  سيدي ،
لن أكذب
كأنني لن أملك أبدًا ، لن أقول أبدًا ولكن لن
أضطر للذهاب إلى الملجأ في أي وقت قريبًا ،
آمل أن أكون قادرًا على البقاء في
المنزل ، اجعلهم قادرين على الاستدارة على الأقل  18
وكن بمفردهم
وكن مثل حسنًا ، كانت أمي قوية مثل
أمي كانت قادرة على القتال
بغض النظر عن ما هذا هو أحلامي ،
من الصعب أنني لن أكذب حتى إذا
كان بفضل الله لن
أذهب  إنه من
قبله أنني ما زلت أطفو ، أبكي كثيرًا
أفكر يا إلهي ، سأفعل هذا
مع طفل آخر
ولكني آمل ألا أضطر أبدًا
إلى بيع الأشياء ، ولكن إذا حدث ذلك ،
فسيحدث ذلك ،
نعم نحن  أنا ذاهب إلى المنزل ،
لسوء الحظ ، لا يمكنني السماح لكم يا رفاق
بمتابعي لأريحه بعيدًا
لأن الملجأ لا يسمح لكم يا رفاق بالتواجد
هناك ، لذا
نعم كان رائعًا  مقابلتك وداعا